[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
q and a section number 48
october 3rd that's right all right
we uh here's what we're going to do we
are going to answer
questions submitted by you during the
first hour and then once you submit
now as many as we can get to and
hopefully those answers will be uh
true and i'm just going to say it i hope
they're timeless timeless
yeah some of them won't be hi well
that's probably true yeah
um so there were literally
14 questions that i really wanted to
come back to from last episode
and if we did that we'd get to almost
done from this episode so we're not
going to get to all of them
we have talked in the past about coming
back to with just you know a couple of
we're just going to pick up questions
that we've had before 14
questions that's seven times two seven
being a biblically special number and
two being the only even prime
[Music]
i'm sorry i guess i'm in that mood i
don't exactly know why that's awesome
okay let's do it um so i have cut it
down to
a mirror uh five well really four
um here uh one of which was something
that was asked of us last time and we
didn't have any answers but you have a
suggestion now the question was
a while ago some of us came up with a
drinking game for the streams if someone
says something that can get them
canceled you drink what do we call it
pariah they call the game pariah
awesome all right i mean i think so you
could also call it which but
i think pariah is better which which is
in w-i-t-c-h
yes which right and the thing yeah it it
harkens back to the
the uh model of witch hunts that i had
on the board a mere day or two prior to
uh my being challenged by all of those
people that i'd never met
over the racism that i didn't have in
may of 2017
may of 2017 may 23rd i believe it was
just before 10 in the morning
could you reconstruct the model of witch
hunts that you had drawn on the board
for your students
i think so presciently i believe so i
believe it was
um a very small number of people
will initiate a witch hunt a substantial
number of people
will attend a witch hunt a
large number of people will stand
silently by
as the witch hunt progresses and a tiny
number of people will
oppose okay um
that actually sounds very much to me
like a question that we weren't it was
it was number 10 here but let's just
jump right to before going back to the
questions from last episode someone
in the last hour said with evergreen
with the woke with any of these things
what percent are consciously
manipulating the movement
can it be zero percent or is the entire
movement like the fortune teller who
believes in his own abilities
so this strikes me as very very much in
line with
this model of which which huntery yeah
that you just described
i would say witch hunt does not involve
anybody necessarily
behaving manipulatively i mean
that doesn't mean that in general
there's not a certain percentage of
manipulators but i don't think any
percentage has to be
for one thing you could get uh organic
um
delusion right right the the
like exactly like with airgut may well
have been
organic delusion yeah a mixture of rumor
and maybe
uh well no actually sorry i the the
the proposed witches uh are
were imagined to have been suffering
from having inhaled air gut which is uh
related to modern synthetic lsd but
is it also true that uh the townspeople
who were
on the witch hunt were imagined oh i
think so yeah yes it was it was it was a
community-wide
problem i'm not saying you have ever
done hallucinogens but anybody who has
done hallucinogens can imagine
that you would be susceptible to
imagining that others were engaged in
magical sorcery based on the distortions
that one gets in their perception
absolutely that that could look like
magic and why aren't you saying that
i've never done hallucinogens you would
want to cast aspersions
no i just uh i don't want you to get
arrested
i don't think having done them is itself
a crime is it um
well that would depend whether you did
them knowingly and i am not saying that
you did
an answer for a different question
perhaps okay
um
no fan of trump but credit where it's
due his stance against
critical race theory is emboldening you
admit he's not a fascist
could he be a temporary solution so this
is you know this was written
last episode not this in light of our
conversation here
um i honestly don't know which of these
candidates is worse
yeah it's hard to know but i will say
from the point of view of this narrow
issue
he's shoring up the federal government
and that which is connected to it so
that critical race theory cannot render
it
insane is necessary
um trump is doing it and
i can't imagine that biden would it
would be putting the finger
a finger in the eye of a constituency
that i think he's counting on
yeah and that his choice of running mate
is explicitly
uh playing with uh you know i don't i
don't think
i don't think that harris is herself um
buying in to the the
the woke ideology but she is perfectly
willing
to throw the rest of us to the wolves if
it helps get her votes and advance her
career
you know there's a uh i think you have
not yet seen the movie vice
i think i have not yet seen the movie
vice back when you and i were which is
about cheney
flying places yeah um i saw it on a
plane
quite liked it and you know it's quite
upfront about its political bias so
anyway
it's approaching no it's anti-changing
but i actually found it quite
sympathetic in its own way okay but yeah
it came from the left and it
acknowledges that
but in any case there's a scene in which
a young cheney who has effectively
signed up with the republicans because
it seemed like the
um the better vessel rather than out of
belief is talking to donald rumsfeld his
mentor
about um i forgotten what the issue was
but somehow rumsfeld
gives him a confusing answer as to
what they are to do and the uh the
cheney character says to him
but donald what do we believe
and rumsfeld laughs in his face
what do we believe and this is sort of
what i think of kamala harris is that
the idea that she believes anything at
all is pretty far-fetched
now she's the most um i don't i don't
know what to think about pence but if we
can
if we think about trump biden and harris
she's the most
explicitly political animal um and you
know maybe that's just
because she's sort of the most coherent
like you can see because she's young
enough to be totally
uh she has all of her faculties and
um they just they don't look honorable
no
looks uh ambitious to the exclusion of
everything else yeah
like belief yeah yeah
okay uh oh another question from last
time
do you have thoughts on prop 16 in
california
right so we didn't answer this because
we thought we remember what it was and
we weren't sure
uh it prop 16 would reverse
prop 200 something something 70 i don't
remember
would reverse a long-standing uh
proposition in california that forbids
affirmative action effectively
so prop 16 if it passes would allow
for hiring decisions and other kinds of
decisions on the basis of
sex race greed whatever greed is a
disability etc
so i am going to carefully and hopefully
without anyone
noticing sidestep the issue of the
particular ballot proposal i should say
you and i both grew up in california and
i regard california's
initiative model extremely frightening
right the way california does ballot
initiatives
is prone to all kinds of manipulation i
remember battles between
industry-written bills and uh
actually corrective bills that were
designed to confuse you
so anyway well we i mean we won't hear
but we could spend a long time talking
about you know we lived through
uh prop 13 right so prop 13
directly changed property tax law and
the cost when it passed was to
defund public education such that
california went from having some of the
best public schools in the country to
having some of the worst
practically overnight so i will just sum
up that phase as
we lived through proposition 13 barely
um all right that's not exactly what
happened but that would be an
interesting conversation to have
um but but not for right now just the
point being neither you nor i have read
proposition 16
um so you you want a sidestep hi friend
uh you want a sidestep speaking directly
to that but but
talk about the issue speak about
affirmative action i would say
affirmative action
i believe is warranted but
it has been a problematic policy in
other words it doesn't do what it's
intended to do
and maybe most importantly it needs to
be temporary
right it needs to be targeted at solving
a problem and at the point that it
solves the problem it needs to be
eliminated or at the point that it fails
to solve the problem it needs to be
eliminated in favor of something else
so what i would say is i am now
in light of the modern sensibilities
surrounding
race and achievement and all very
concerned
that the sensibility is oh
this is a problem it will always be a
problem therefore we will need this
remedy permanently and anytime you set
affirmative action in motion with the
idea that it is the new order forever
um you've done something wrong so uh i
would i would like to have a
clear-headed conversation about the idea
that there's a difference between the
justification of a remedy the
effectiveness of that remedy
and the durability of that remedy and
that
even those of us who are fiercely
committed to the idea
of a fair society and recognize that
society is
biased in ways that demand a remedy may
not be in favor of these remedies that
have been deployed
because they haven't done what they were
supposed to do
and what they have done is created a
whole kind
a whole set of unintended consequences
that are very negative for the
populations in question
yeah and i i should have looked up when
the proposition that 16 would um would
obliterate past but my my suspicion is
that somewhere 20 25 years ago or so
and the modern sensibility as you put it
is that racism in particular is
everywhere
and it is unsolvable this is obviously
an attempt to solve it which is
inconsistent itself with the ideology of
it being unsolvable
but it also like the only reason to
reinstate
affirmative action um in in particular
in california is if the last whatever it
is 15 20 25 years without it
has revealed a greater chasm
than what what was occurring before that
proposition 200 something was passed
right like
you need to actually compare and you
know it's impossible to do it perfectly
because you can't control for time
but what was you know what did the
disparities
um look like before proposition 200
whatever it was was passed
what does it look like uh two years ago
say before the
before this has gotten completely to
fever pitch as right now
uh and if it hasn't gotten worse
and my guess is it's actually gotten
quite a bit better
then on what basis would you possibly um
seek out a solution under which
conditions were worse than they are now
it doesn't make any sense uh and you
know this isn't exactly affirmative
action but
the kind of you know the what do you
call it the modern predicament whatever
whatever this
this modern insanity is is revealing
itself and this isn't like i say exactly
affirmative action but didn't
san francisco mayor london breed
actually and like what an appropriate
name here
um actually decide that she was going to
start
she right she start paying
black women a thousand dollars
for their pregnancies but only black
women i believe this is correct
unbelievable it's one unbelievable
thing in a long list of unbelievable
things which tells us something about
where we've ended up and how far we have
fallen from the most basic principles
that the republic is is founded on
yeah um all right so okay uh
penultimate question from episode 47
what are the differences between the
sperm that gets to fertilize the eggs
from those that don't
how does this affect humans born from in
vitro fertilization
totally the sperm that fertilize the egg
those are
winners yeah i mean just almost by
definition yeah we're all from winners
yeah well here's what you want to know
and this is why you took the time to
write that question to a pair
of biologists
at large the
phenotype of the sperm that is to say
its physical nature in the world
is the result of the genotype of
the individual that produced it not the
particular subset of genes that it
carries i believe that
remains the conclusion of the study that
has been done on this
really so so to put that into slightly
less uh
biologically dense language what you
just said and i did not know this to be
true what you are claiming is true
is that uh all of the sperm
from a single individual will have the
same phenotype
uh obviously there will be
noise because there's going to be
differences in the developmental
environment for each sperm
but it will not be heritable from
the genes carried within that sperm
but there will be sort of cellular
developmental differences
i don't know that they would be
measurable i just it would be impossible
for them to be zero
so and and yet some sperm seem to be
faster than others
right so you think that's just about
like initial conditions getting stuck in
an eddy or something
something like that yeah um so i mean
you can imagine
for one thing uh path path literal path
dependence
and the exhaustion of some sperm based
on whatever energy reserves they had
would leave them swimming slower at the
point you chose to measure them
um you got me envisioning salmon
right which are bigger a bit yes um
multicellular too
yeah i mean this is just among other
differences among
other differences yes um
jokes suggest themselves but i'm not
going to make any of them
not here not here not ever really
well i think you will we will find out
yes
they might not though no they they will
not um but yes so
my understanding and this is you know i
i don't know this
i i know it from a study with bob
trivers
back in college so it's possible
something has upended this result or
that there's more nuance to it
but yes the the differences in the sperm
are not the result of genetic
differences of the subset of genes so
to take to take the
um caricature version to establish this
if you had a
loser parent and a winner parent and the
shuffling of jeans resulted in one sperm
so you're a dude who's got a loser
parent and a winter parent
and you are creating sperm each of which
have half of your genome and some of
those spur will actually be entirely
from your loser parent and some of them
will be entirely from your winter parent
although that's really really rare
because most of them will be mixed
will pretty much never happen very
occasionally some of your sperm will be
100
related to your mother and not at all
related to your father no actually it
can't be
can't be that um because there's no y
chromosome from your mom but right
um but very occasionally you will get
sperm almost entirely from one parent or
from the other same with eggs
yeah yeah um actually i want to go back
and check
so the sperm will be x bearing or y
bearing
50 50. right um barring unusual so a
sperm could be a hundred percent
from the guy who made it made its dad's
genome
but it could not be a hundred percent
from the guy who made its mom's genome
ah uh no because
because of an x-bearing sperm could be a
hundred percent but a y-bearing spur so
half of the sperm
can't be entirely from the mom's genome
this is they were in the weeds but
so anyway so i don't i i would be
curious whether this
result has uh remained robust in all of
those years since i
last encountered it yeah because we've
learned a ton about epigenetics among
other things
but in any case even the the the
preponderance of
loser genes would not affect the
likelihood of the sperm
succeeding now there are exceptions
to this so what does what does drive
which sperm succeeds
well so i was going to get to uh
intergenomic conflict
and sperm sabotage so effective but
that's with different
like that's that inner genomic conflict
is going to be
uh if the female has made it with more
than one male
um or no you're talking about egg versus
sperm i'm no i'm talking about
things like t haplotype in mice
which sperm that carry one allele
sabotage sperm that carry the other
allele so although they reduce
the the likelihood of the individual
making those sperm of fertilizing an egg
if it fertilizes an egg it will
certainly be the t haplotype so even
though the phenotypes appear to be the
same if this result from 30 years ago
holds
there is still antigenomic conflict
between sperm from the same
dude at the same time yeah there can be
okay right and so and there are many
different versions of
these things t haplotype is the best
studied or at least was the best studied
of them but
um so these are uh driving genetic
elements that's
that uh sabotage the individual in favor
of their own
continuance which is of course exactly
how you would expect genes to behave
yeah and trivers and austin burt have
now i mean it's probably been 10 years
now but they
they were already sort of working i
think on their book on
inter and introgenomic conflict i
believe
um and that's that's out now so that we
could probably look at that
to see what is up to date here um
yeah and does this affect humans born
from in vitro fertilization
probably um
well in vitro fertilization i don't
really know the
the mechanism of ivf so the mechanism of
ivf
the primary one is just basically the
physical introduction
of genome of sperm genome into
an egg um so with a needle
yeah and that can have destructive
effects but i think it's physically
destructive of the egg right so the
question
yeah is about the competition
about the competition and whether the
competition between sperm means that the
sperm that carry the genes that are
better
tend to fertilize the eggs which would
be
in some way purifying so i think what
goes on with ivf is
of a very different nature but i don't
know
okay final question from last time would
you rather fight one horse-sized duck or
100 duck-sized horses
wait wait wait would i rather fight one
duck-sized horse-sized duck
or a hundred duck-sized horses
i'm good either way really oh yeah
that's cheating you can't say that
all right then i would rather fight
the
i think i'd rather fight the uh the
little horses yeah me too
yeah duck-sized horses ducks last words
100 ducks it's a lot
like you know if it was 10 it'd be
obvious you know one horse sized duck or
10 duck size horses but
um horses that are duck sized it's just
going to be pretty easy to take out i
think
yeah and they yeah they're just not
going to be able to do much i mean
that's a lot of them and they and
being horses they might team up but yeah
as long as they're not rabid rabid
horses yeah
couldn't drag me away rabbit horses
couldn't drink
no no not a thing okay okay next
question this came from the discord
ser the discord discussion this week
what do you think about the fact that
there is nowhere on earth to go in order
to be a sovereign individual under no
jurisdiction but your own there's no
opt-out to any and all societies and
this came with a bunch more
um sort of background but um fascinating
terrifying sad question oh yeah actually
i spent a lot of time thinking about the
consequences of this
yeah um basically it's like this
we have signed you up
for a deal that you can't opt out of who
we the
civilization yeah and that means that
civilization has obligations to you that
it's not meeting ah
right if it's gonna sign you up if you
can't go be a hunter-gatherer somewhere
right then the point is it is
taking something from you and it has an
obligation to deliver on
its promise to be decent to you and from
this i believe
that the entire obligation to create
societies that
are fair and functional and
that free people to engage in things
that are
meaningful all of that derives
from this fact that you don't have
another choice right that's why we have
to do the right thing
yeah and anyway yeah i think it's a very
important principle and i i it
weirdly as much as it seems deeply
philosophical and remote it is one of
the things that drives me is that i
think we are just not living up to this
obligation and we have to fix that
all right good thank you from a fellow
portlander who happens to sit across the
political aisle
your actions and commentary help lessen
the lonesome feeling of disagreeing with
the far-left socio-political landscape
of our hometown
it's a comment not a question but uh we
appreciate that yeah thank you
major to coverly uh from uh catch 22
mental maturity does not arise from the
youth culture
how do you create so i think there's a
either a typo here or a word missing so
i'm not sure exactly how do you create
now as a mob's foundation
to create a society focusing on growing
mature thinking
humans and i don't remember i just for
this vague glimmering
of asimov's foundation but i can't quite
remember exactly what it is but i think
we can interpret the question without
that
even you know how
that scene you know the the getting rid
of the
great loyalty the glorious loyalty oath
crusade um
was done in heller's imagining with a
respected
elder coming in and saying no uh-uh
first not first not for me and then oh
obviously not for anyone else either
so how i guess there's two possible
questions here
um what do we do absent those like
who do we look to absent that kind of
person
now and also how do we make more of them
how do we make those people
well i mean this will be uncontroversial
for
you me and most of our audience but one
thing is you have to stop
demonizing masculinity yeah and that's
not to say that the people who wield
this stuff
have to be men right it's but the point
is
those are characteristics that have
traditionally been seen in men
they have been seen in extraordinary
women who have very often
found their names inscribed in history
because of it but the point is
those characteristics that cause you not
to
obsess over every little slight
and to regard being tough and getting
stuff done
and you know stoicism and all of that
right
those characteristics need to be
resurrected and being told that they are
toxic
is itself toxic right it is dangerous to
society
to tell people that um you know
bucking up and getting the job done is
no longer on the menu because what we
need to do
is you know all come into work and
immediately cry on each other's
shoulders
no right that just doesn't work and
so how you do that in this era where
to even voice that runs the risk of
you know you being portrayed as uh
callous worse toxic
that's you know that's the thing we have
to get around is you've got to cultivate
that stuff in yourself
right you got to toughen yourself up and
you got to not be shy about
talking to your kids and others about
the fact that these are actually
not only desirable characteristics but
it is
necessary not everybody has to have them
but you need
tough people yeah and and to to those
adults who do
oversee large swaths of employees for
instance like all parents should be
inculcating this and their children
regardless of the sex of their children
but if you are an employer who who
has you know run spotify and the
employers are threatening to walk out if
they don't
uh start censoring some of joe rogan's
podcasts
or jk rowling's publisher whose
employees are threatening to walk out if
they don't censor her
or google whose employees
um whose employees won with the james
damore memo which didn't say what a lot
of people thought it said
and which did say a lot of very true
things and
uh not only the employees managed to get
you know
make a coup happen but what was less
well-reported was afterwards a bunch of
them
took sick days because they were too
emotional to come to work now
come on like why would you let the
people who are too emotional to work
drive policy don't let people who are
too emotional to work
drive policy that's not seen right
that's not saying
and we saw actually one of the few
examples of
um the proper response to this
uh by the head of coinbase oh i don't
know i think it's
a story so this is a ceo who put out a
thing that says look
we care about injustice but that's not
what coinbase is
coinbase is about something and we are
not going to be able to accomplish it
if what we are doing is coming to work
for
the purposes of therapy and so his point
was look
leave that stuff at home right and he's
taken a tremendous amount of crap for it
yeah that
but here's the thing can anybody really
doubt that in a world
you know the woke will try to stamp that
example out because in order for them
not to lose there have to be
no examples of companies that do that
otherwise what you will get
is the hegemony of those who have
resisted you know we've been saying this
from the beginning
if you've got engineering schools that
are woke and other engineering schools
that aren't woke
then ultimately the ones that aren't
woke will will
be in charge of everything because they
will make better bridges and buildings
and all of that other stuff and
so their stuff is less likely to fail
right and so the point is
you know get out of yourself long enough
to recognize
that whatever thing you're trying to fix
with your hard coding of your morality
you're making it fragile with respect to
all the things it's in competition with
well most of these people advocating for
these things uh have never made anything
real
and they wouldn't recognize the
difference between a real thing and a
socially constructed thing clearly but
you know based on the fact that they
keep on making
ludicrous claims like biological sex
isn't real and math isn't real and
you know they they clearly just have
long since lost the plot
yeah and why are we listening to them
why is anyone caving to them well
unfortunately the answer is pretty
simple
and pretty mundane right first of all i
do think you know it's uncomfortable to
say but a lot of the people who are
initiating this are people who intuit
that
they will not be well served by
meritocracy they won't be winners right
and i don't think this is necessarily on
them i think society has
served them very badly and so the fact
that they perceive that in a meritocracy
they will lose
and so they are fighting meritocracy
because actually
that's the route for them to wellness
that's something we have to deal with
but once they have articulated that
position
and once they are exerting it in a
muscular
fashion then the game theory for the
individual who wants to dodge the
penalty
is to simply embrace it which causes it
to grow and spread
so it's like those two things are
sufficient to explain it
so two things um by you invoking a
muscular fashion for the woke you caused
a cognitive dissonance in my brain that
i'm just having a hard time escaping
from the
the most of the most individuals don't
appear to be very muscular
it turns out um yes the threat is
muscular yes no i know what you meant
i just like i i got the like the visual
image
muscular phenotype that's not that's not
what the woke is
um are you
making the claim which is pretty uh
pretty audacious
if you are but i just want to see if i
heard you right
that many of the people arguing against
effectively enlightenment values
which includes the idea of meritocracy
which is not to say that we think that
we have a perfect meritocracy or even
that it can be
perfectly obtained in a democratic
system but that we can aspire
to it but are you saying that you think
that those who are arguing against it
are doing so in part because
uh they would not win in a fair
meritocracy that they are somehow they
have
through through maybe fault of their own
maybe no fault of their own through some
combination of
factors into which they were born and
handed
um that they would not be winning and
therefore trying to create a new kind of
system
yes but it's important to get all of the
pieces of that and then to add one so
the pieces are all the pieces that i
just laid out or
yes what i don't want to be lost is you
know everybody
who's over in that left cabal
is a loser my point is those who would
argue against meritocracy itself
i believe have intuited that it would
not serve them and therefore
they have very little to lose in
challenging the idea that it could even
work right
but the other part i want to make sure
is heard by people
is to the extent that you have large
numbers of people who cannot compete in
a meritocracy
that is not necessarily their fault in
fact right largely is unlikely to be
their fault it's the result
of a system that decided to drug them
for profit decided to mis-educate them
so as to create
cogs to operate machines that don't even
exist anymore
so babysat them with screens babysat
them with screens
fed them porn whatever it did it created
people who are not well constructed
to do [ __ ] and you know gave them junk
everything
it gave them junk sex junk media junk
everything
and so their rebellion is to be expected
but that does not mean that we need to
humor the idea
that the enlightenment was always and
only a tool of oppression
that meritocracy is itself a trick
you know those things are garbage and
nonsense and the answer should be
the quicker we get to a meritocracy that
where you are incentivized to succeed
and given the tools with which to do it
the better right that's the thing we
want a fair meritocracy well that's
synonymous but
yeah um but that's the objective yeah
okay suppose we could create a digital
emperor has no clothes mechanism for
people in general organizations
as in with encrypted smart contracts or
something like that
what would the game theoretic
consequences of that of that
be struggling to understand exactly what
is it
the ability to
[Music]
indicate anonymously that the emperor
has no clothes and when a sufficient
number of people
yeah sort of uh anonymizing
whistleblowing
so that uh it it only manifests maybe
you only become public
i i don't know i'm putting stuff on here
and this may not be what the
person asking question was implying but
what i
envisioned envisage is
an anonymous ability to whistle blow and
at the point that some
say fraction of people who could
possibly whistleblow have done so
then it becomes a matter of public
record something like this
would be a total disaster okay um
yeah because so this is one of these
cases where
i mean i may also that may be none of
that maybe yeah yeah
well i can't can't figure out exactly
how it would work
a we have versions of this
you know hr is a ham-fisted attempt to
create
a mechanism to protect people and it's
now been weaponized
right but the you know the digital
emperor has no closed mechanism
if if the ai can't get woke right like
hr has been captured hr has gone woke in
almost every organization that we've
heard about right
and so the idea would be that the
algorithm can't go woke the algorithm
can have a lot other things that are
wrong with it but if the algorithm can't
get captured in the same way that hr has
been captured
might this not be a way to end run uh
some of some of the problems that we're
seeing in organizations my sense is the
ai is woke as [ __ ]
okay um that why why well because you've
seen it at places like google where
it picks up ethos and starts trying you
know
it it's it's a version of the paperclip
maximizer
it's woken it's in that scenario and
it's you know it's
sometimes sometimes presumably will feed
you
you know extreme right ideology if
that's the area no no it does it does
worse than this and i mean you know it's
not to say that it can't
be utilized to anything positive but the
idea of mechanizing it
actually just adds a layer of
hazard and
you know i can imagine if you had a
whistleblower automated whistleblower
yada yada
right then the woke would be i mean in
fact they already are
right this is this is what i believe
happened to the articles of unity
account on twitter
was that a bunch of uh woke
folks who didn't like unity from the
beginning because
it wasn't woke um
they reported to twitter
triggering an algorithmic process that
sidelined the account
that then resulted in some person with
discretion on the inside
using the excuse so there's a you know
social media has its own kind of problem
because you can game the social feedback
thing um but even you know absent
that kind of feedback because why would
you build that into
such a mechanism as is being asked here
um
you still ultimately need the human with
discretion and so you're still dealing
with a human with discretion
who is um receiving the outputs of the
ai
and and that that will always that will
always have
a potential flaw so we should be getting
through more of these uh you
i see you forming some ironic thing to
say remembering that
the the movie war game starts with them
removing the people with discretion
thinking they were solving a problem
and creating a new problem which i think
is likely
this is written telegraphically
do women have instinct
can you read this i can't i can't read
this i can't i can't quite
make sense of this question do women
have instinct
to continually refine women's intuition
of human behavior to assess
trust as an alternative to male reliance
on violence
thinking of murder shows um well yeah i
can't quite get the exact question out
of there but
let's just say um
all intuition is about
subtle patterns and
the thing that we don't get about
intuition is that we sort of have the
sense that it is
uh you know god-given or if you're
more of a scientific materialist you may
imagine that it's written in the genes
that you're wired to perceive certain
things and
undoubtedly you are but the intuition is
really about
experience that is hard to uh
that is hard to reconcile consciously
right so you may have the experience
that people
who have a certain you know shifty way
of
of standing are a hazard or
untrustworthy
right it's very hard to write exactly
what the rule is what you're even
noticing
but these intuitions can be well tutored
if they have
uh if they're built on experience that's
actually informative that is to say
more signal than noise they can be
cruddy if they're built
on noisy data or pure noise
and so anyway yes women's intuition is
of course
going to be augmented
uh continual selection
whether it's exactly about male reliance
on violence
hard to say undoubtedly women have an
intuition about
those tendencies of men
good something yeah there's there's
something
very interesting to be done here that
maybe maybe we need a bit more
time or words to to pull out
can you our people wolf is
out of control today oh my god she's
terrible um i didn't say she was
terrible
she's just snorting and rolling around
the floor a lot
uh can you comment on yuval harare's
book sapiens is it true that the
cognitive revolution was driven by man's
ability to create fictions
as in money religion states etc also is
it true that these things are actually
fictions so gosh that's three different
questions right yeah
um neither of us i think neither of us
have read sapiens
i read part of it i mean i picked it up
and i looked through it a little bit um
i i did not not read it because i
thought it was terrible
it just didn't really grab me um it's
been recommended by
smart people who know something about
evolution um so
you know but neither of us can speak
directly to whether or not
um it it struck us as insightful and
true
um but so if we take that part out of it
and just
uh address the rest of the question as
if it is not referring to harare's book
is it true that the cognitive revolution
was driven by man's ability to create
fictions such as money religion and
states
um just taking that question that's
wrong yeah um because our you know the
size of our brain
just just in terms of not the software
but the hardware of which we are made
has been more or less the same on change
for about 200 000 years
so um money what are the three things he
puts here
money religion and states um are all we
think
quite a bit newer than 200 000 years old
so um
the the cognitive revolution um that
allowed us to have the size of brain
and specifically the size of prefrontal
cortex it allows us to think forward and
reflect backward and tie those
two two things together into the present
uh is much older than these
things um and then is it true that these
things are actually fictions
and they're not fictions they're not
fictions they're abstractions and they
are
um human constructs
yeah i would say those two things are
close kin yeah but uh
human construct does not make a thing
fiction no right
um so a what we've said elsewhere
what came from dick alexander on this
front
was that it was an arms race between
humans at the point that humans become
their most prominent hostile force their
own most prominent hostile force
that arms race sets up the increase in
cognition what does that mean
it means that that cognition was largely
built around things like understanding
the state of mind of your competitor or
your enemy
in order to model their behavior and
either
parasitize it or challenge it so anyway
that's a pretty good model
um is that unrelated to what you have
called fictions and what we would
maybe revise to abstractions it's not
unrelated
right you're right your competitor's
mindset
is an abstraction to you right and it
can be better or worse
and does that capacity to generate
the abstract model of your competitors
mindset ultimately result in your
ability to
abstract value to currency from barter
yeah it probably does so it's related
but probably not
causal in the way that you lay out here
and um i guess just one more thing about
that
the way that you just built up the
analysis
it clearly originates or you know
there's something sort of more
fundamental than
money religion states which is theory of
mind you know imagining
what your competitor's mental state is
and
and recognizing that it is not
inherently the same as your own which is
something that i think it's like
two-year-old baby humans uh can begin to
do
well that's not even unique to humans so
you know um
there are we we know that for instance
dolphins have theory of mind in some
circumstances elephants do
baboon's terrific book baboon
metaphysics
um by cheney and seyfarth explores in
some depth all the ways that baboons
appear to have theory of mind it can
really recognize
the ways in which what one baboon may
feel and desire
and understand to be true can also
recognize that a baboon sitting across
the way
understands other things to be true and
desires different things so
you know if it's and baboons and we
share a most recent common ancestor that
must go back
boy i'm going to be completely making
this up but at least 20 million years
i would say if we share most recent
common ancestors with chimps and
madoba's at 6 million years ago
the other apes probably 10 12 you know
are basically baboons or old world
monkeys and so that's gotta be at least
20 million years ago i think
they're all world monkeys and old school
monkeys no they're definitely old school
yeah yeah absolutely wrapped on the
knuckles really
og yeah original gangster monkeys
got it yep okay um
is there an adaptive use to something
like bullying
also what's up with mail pattern
baldness
is that an attack yeah why does that
persist when it seems to be a handicap
so that is two questions
uh maybe we'll do just do one of them
since uh we want to get through more of
these which one do you want to take on
male pattern baldness or bullying
uh bullying okay um by the way this is
real
i'm if i have male pattern baldness it's
a hundred years behind schedule yeah
um trans men begin to experience male
pattern baldness which
suggests that it is a direct effect
mechanistically of testosterone
yeah yeah um okay so
bullying first of all
this is part of bullying may be the
pathological version of something
for which i think actually in this case
we maybe do
have uh non-patho pathological names for
the things that are short of it but
one wants to be very careful if you take
all of the things that could be
portrayed as bullying
out of the schoolyard you will get
fragile snowflakey kids yep right
if you want to create robust adults that
can endure stuff
then they need to be exposed to stuff
including not so nice
uh colleagues giving them a hard time on
the playground and so
bullying toughens you up and the fact is
you
probably better off being toughened up
by the
kid in your school yard who's maybe a
little rough around the edges than you
are
being pampered through school and then
getting out into the real world and
running into somebody who really has you
know
no stake in your well-being in an
iterated sense
going forward so i'm going to name drop
just a little bit here i was actually
just in a conversation i don't think you
know this
um while editing the childhood chapter i
was either the childhood or the school
chapter of our
of our book um and i i had made a claim
i'd written something and made a claim
about uh bullies uh having
very short-term success but long-term
being you know losing power
in in the scenario in those situations
where bullies are allowed to persist and
that the children themselves
hopefully in mixed age groups are
allowed to basically do
do the business on their own without
having adults come in and inform them of
who's the boss and who's not
um and i realized that i just i had this
in my head but i didn't have a reference
for it and i couldn't find one so i
approached lenore skinesi our friend who
is the founder of among other things let
grow uh she became famous many years ago
as uh the nation's worst mom i think
when she
lef um allowed her then nine-year-old
maybe to ride the new york subway
um and of course she is very much not
the nation's worst mom
um in fact she's probably one of the
best and she has become quite an
advocate for free play
and unstructured play and unsupervised
play in children
and i asked her and she said she i don't
know but peter gray
who is a researcher on play not just in
american children specifically in the
sudbury schools
which have a lot of unstructured play
with mixed age groups but also in
hunter-gatherer children
she put me in touch with him and in
conversation with him an email
conversation with with peter gray
he says you know i have no references to
to support this but
i i know that it's something i've seen
and i also
i can also point to um other personal
observations
of other researchers from various
hunter-gatherer societies so from
hunter-gatherer societies from
pre-industrial societies
to the playgrounds at sudbury schools in
in the new in new england uh yes this
would seem to be the case that that
bullies um are uh are a strategy
that show up over and over and over
again and under circumstances where
children are allowed
to deal with their own troubles uh
bullies tend to lose
in the end yeah bully is not a good
strategy right
right and so again i want to draw the
distinction
bully might be the pathological version
but
giving your you know taking the piss out
of your friends
might be the wholesome version of it
that results in you knowing where you're
vulnerable fixing the problem being
stronger in the end and all of those
things and so
you know i don't want to defend bullying
because maybe it's just bad but
that's you know it's bad like uh
water is bad when you drown right you
know
yeah it's not an indictment of water no
i mean and there were boys i mean this
this is actually one of the themes of
the way that we think this evolutionary
lens you know dyslexia
maladaptive or adaptive right like oh
okay
um you can't actually do it that way
yeah you can't do it that way
okay my ten-year-old son
david i apologize if i mispronouncing
his name my ten-year-old son
david wants to know the egg the first
chicken is born in is it really a
chicken egg
or an egg of a pre-chicken if the latter
then chicken came first not the egg we
love your voice of sanity stay
safe yeah you've resurrected
the chicken and egg problem which was
neatly solved well it resurrects it only
really if you add
a little semantic thing to the question
which came first
the chicken or the chicken egg yeah
right and so that you know that's not
in fact the question as it usually is
asked and
maybe that's what they're trying to ask
but um
but really you know which came first the
chicken or the egg clearly the egg
because eggs predate chickens which came
first the chicken or the chicken egg
which is what this
uh this question resurrects perhaps
what do you think well i mean look let's
put it this way
i am not a fan of sophistry but were you
to get involved in sophistry were you to
take it up maybe as a hobby
you could make an argument that the
chicken came first because the eggshell
goes on after the chicken egg is
fertilized
little known fact um and therefore
if the chicken is synonymous with the
zygote
then the chicken shell came second
again that's pure sophistication okay
you want you want to play at sophistry
yeah i do
yeah okay so in what universe mm-hmm
is that how we play at soviet street do
we begin our questions where they want
universe in what universe
that's a good start that was threatening
yeah in what universe do you imagine
that the egg and the eggshell are
synonymous
whoa i know in what
well in this universe oh sweetheart
um no it's a terrible answer it's a
terrible answer i don't know i
i i don't think so so yeah so then we
have a temporal
um thing which you know which came first
the question is already temporal but
then
the egg exists and then the egg stops
being formed and somewhere in the middle
of the egg being formed the chicken
comes to be oh
it depends it depends on what the
definition of
is is at some level this is why this is
why i dislike sophistry as a mode of
analysis
yes did you know that the sophists were
paid tutors
no i didn't they were paid tutors they
were paid to be pain in the asses yeah
pains depends on how many people paid
them how many asses you've got yeah
yeah all right in a debate dyson a
preacher
called jordan peterson a mean old white
man and an upholder of patriarchy
then he invited jordan peterson to a
black church if absence of religion
creates a void for wokeness to fill
what do you make of this love you both
you know i might the very short answer
is that
you know nothing dyson did in that uh
you know well-known debate looked like
honorable
christianity or religiosity to me and
you know and i say that with no
you know without christianity or
religiosity to me but um
nothing in the teachings of jesus uh
suggests that calling peop
someone a medial white man or an
upholder of patriarchy has anything to
do with
uh that's just inconsistent with what
the new testament is trying to inform
people of as a way to behave
yeah so um it's i think i think he
dyson whatever his name is uh eric
michael maybe
um is just a hypocrite and he's he's
he's not an upstanding religious person
as he would appear to be if he's
inviting peterson to a black church or
if he is he's got work to do
he's not getting it right okay um you
know and for one thing i mean we can say
jordan's a friend he's not a mean old
white guy yeah
he's a bit traditional in some ways that
we're different but
but also not an upholder of patriarchy
not an uphold or patriarchy
in fact he's a fan of the ways in which
we are different right right so he's
you know uh sort of rooting for that
difference to
to be dealt with responsibly and so
anyway
um he's a cool guy he feels
other people's uh tribulations
intensely which is not something that a
mean old white guy
does right he's somebody who cares a
great deal and it has
been very costly to him so in any case
yes i would say
uh dyson missed it by one mechanism or
another
yeah your dog is almost under your chair
there
be aware you've stated men and women
need to
know renegotiate terms i agree
specifically in regards to child rearing
what would be the ideal arrangement for
parents to feel fulfilled at home and
work both part time every other day
question mark
boy it's going to depend on all of the
particulars yeah
all right um we
were in a really lucky position when our
kids were were
tiny because we both had
full-time jobs that allowed such
flexibility um
and we had on-campus child care that
allowed us to do part-time
such that we could you know really both
be co-parenting in every regard with the
exception of the anatomically mandated
stuff
yeah which is to say once they're born
just just breastfeeding
yeah and we had almost zero commute
we lived walking distance from work and
the kids daycare
and biking distances and biking distance
and we biked with the kids
to daycare dropped them off uh we had
special tandems and
used them to drop the kids at daycare so
that was really good they were writing
by the time they were two they were each
on the back of the kidback tandem
yep but all of this the symmetry allowed
you know the symmetry in our both our
jobs
and and all of that was really useful
from the point of view of not having to
divide up the
labor of it too much there's obviously
stuff that you do there are novel
opportunities which
you know the um the interesting one
is breast pumping
allows some of the feeding
to be done by the father now is that a
good
idea and there's at least one way in
which it's a hazardous idea
which has to do with the fact that the
breast milk
has circadian messages in it yeah so
let's just give a shout out here to
josie josie jarvis
who was one of our students who um um
this this is an idea that is a little
bit out there in the literature but she
really dove deep and actually i've been
in contact with her a little bit because
this is
this is another idea that hopefully is
going to end up in the book
but the circadian information the
information that's in breast milk that
is circadian in nature
may mean for instance that if you pump
breast milk
in the hopes that for instance your
partner who's not lactating
can do a feeding in the middle of the
night and that partner gives the baby
breast mouth that was pumped at noon
you might actually wake that kid up and
render a night without sleep for any of
you
whereas if you pay attention to when it
was expressed when the breast milk was
expressed
um uh that you do a very much better job
of getting your kid under some sort of
circadian cycle it is very much more
like the one that you were on
right yeah so anyway yes that yeah um so
hey josie if you're out there yeah um
it's yeah it's it's going to be harder
to be
symmetrical if you don't already have
symmetrical stuff and yeah we didn't we
didn't plan it out that way we just
ended up with like literally identical
jobs
yeah right um and living really close to
both our jobs
and the daycare which was part of part
of the jobs and really at that point the
daycare was
was exquisite it was so good and we
could do it part-time and all of this
um that said there is real value in
division of labor
and many of the ways that male and
female roles
have been divided in the past are no
longer necessary
some of them will persist for anatomic
and physiological reasons
uh some of them will persist for um
persistent differences
in sex well i guess this is still
anatomic and physiological like you know
in
the study that i like to bring up this
provost murdoch 1973 review
of pre-industrial uh societies finds
that in every society they looked at
that has
uh you know marine mammal hunting
it's always the men who do it this just
isn't something that you send women to
do also you don't send women into the
mines
yeah and i should say none of those
three things showed up in our
relationship
yes you you never hunted whales went
down to the mountains always catch and
release
although i mean the third one that i say
i know you're joking
yeah especially with the blue whales
yeah wow yeah it's just hard to get him
in the boat for anything yeah exactly
you might need a bigger boat i yes yes
um
but you know with lumbering i mean like
when this tree fell on our driveway
in the windstorm that just before
smokopolis um
you know you were the guy with the
chainsaw and you know i like i
i know my way around a lot of power
tools and i've enjoyed making a lot of
things a lot of power tools and
chainsaws ain't one of them
and uh you know that's it it could be
different
right it absolutely could be different
but um you know most of these gender
norms
um don't need to be the way they are
anymore but it's also true that across
cultures there are a whole lot of
gendered activities
that it depends on the culture as to
which gender does it so you know weaving
for instance is highly gendered in most
cultures that have been looked at
but sometimes it's only women who do it
and sometimes it's only men who do it
and that suggests not that men or women
are better at weaving
but that there is a value in having
gendered activities
so that itself is something that we can
unpack what now
i was just going to say that lumbering
about is the province of men
i suppose um and weaving can be either
depending on the alcohol women do not
weave well enough alone
oh wow oh that's where we're going i
don't know
yeah um so yeah obviously we can
we can talk about this for for a long
time but maybe we'll stop there for
for now zach how long are we at uh
you're about 50 minutes
50. okay well uh we are going to
stop there for for okay sorry
uh we're not gonna stop stop we are
going to um
move to this hour's super chat questions
okay i am a public school teacher being
told
that i must return to in-person school
in two weeks
i'm in multiple high-risk categories if
you were in my shoes would you return to
work or quit
quitting halfway through my contract may
affect future employment
oh my god yeah um
boy i mean it it depends
not just on your risk from covid
but your financial risk from not working
and potentially not being able to get
more work yep well i would say
you want to think very carefully about
unfortunately the problem is at the
beginning
you're liable and we don't know where
you're writing from but no
um you know if you were in la
then you might be able to use open
windows
and fans or something yep to reduce your
risk a great deal
you know in conjunction with a good mask
yeah you could do something like that
yeah so there's not only is the answer
going to be different depending on both
your risk from covet and your financial
risk but also
geography so that's that's just a third
thing here in
a column of things to think about yeah
so anyway what i would say is
yeah we can't we can't really help you
with the analysis
fully because you do have these two
competing things and we don't know
anything about one of them yeah um but
you can within whatever
risk is coming to you from your
environment do
an awful lot to protect yourself and
reduce the likelihood
of your getting sick and if you do get
sick reduce the likelihood that it is
severe so i would say yeah
so viral load being an indicator a good
predictor of
both whether or not you get sick so
exposure to
the amount of virus to which you are
exposed is a good predictor of both
uh whether you get sick or not and if
you do get sick how sick you get
both of those things and the other thing
i would say that's a
very big one is vitamin d right so
outdoor exposure to the sun you can also
supplement vitamin
d but vitamin d appears to be
one of the most protective things that
you can
have available to you matt ridley just
did a good piece on this
oh yeah um yeah and his point was
nobody's pushing vitamin d there's no
profit in it yeah
uh always but i mean i feel like
yeah it doesn't mean you can't and i
gotta say i feel like
actually you know given the market
economy that we live in
a number of uh a number of companies
could be pushing that as part of their
advertising when so i was
i while you were on your patreon call
this morning
i was out stand-up boarding on the
willamette and it was a cool cloudy day
but it's still just completely gorgeous
i saw
two kingfishers fighting over the water
and uh an
osprey flew overhead with a fish and his
or her i can't suck some at that
distance i can't sex him at all um
in his talons and you know great blue
heron that i float you know paddled
five feet from so and this is on the
willamette in just outside i guess i was
the
city of portland limits but you know
extraordinary um
and i'm out there getting my vitamin d
right and no one else i it was it was
early on a saturday that wasn't a
beautiful saturday
by most by most metrics um there weren't
a ton of other people out there
but you know no one's masked as they
shouldn't be if they're alone in a boat
or in a kayak or on a stand-up paddle
board or fishing there are a lot of
people fishing out today
um and why
not have people selling fishing gear and
stand-up paddleboards and kayaks
and you know other things that you do
outside
hiking boots you know why doesn't rai
like why aren't a lot of these places
that actually their business model is
about getting outside and being outside
um they could start to do this that
would be both a public service and it
would help their bottom line
so um i fully agree with that that we
ought to be
heavily emphasizing those things which
are protective which
you know oftentimes you should be doing
anyway yeah um
but yesterday i was at a ups store i
needed to get something notarized and
there was a line
and i was in there and the line was
inside
it was inside even though it was like 74
degrees outside and
well they had the door open yeah but
anyway as i'm standing there in line and
the line is moving very slowly i'm
thinking about this
model about okay has anybody sick been
here
do they stand in line for a long time
exhaling is this room
full up with high viral load in which
case
you know it's not like you get it
instantly but it means that if you
continue to breathe it eventually you do
and so
anyway i made an arrangement with the
guy i was in line in front of that i was
going to go stand outside as long as i
was waiting
right that was not
a perfectly straightforward thing to
negotiate but the point is
you've got a good model then you can
look at the situation and you can say
okay what can i do here to drop
my risk to a level that i can accept it
and i'm just curious i don't know which
ups store you're at but would it have
been possible for them to have the line
outside the store
they could have yes and we should we
should
want them to do exactly that like give
it another month and that won't make
sense right so if there's no awnings
you know it might be pouring and in a
lot of parts of the country it would
just be too cold
um potentially but um you know i i feel
like i would
always prefer to be outside
than inside in a enclosed space
where you don't know who's been sick and
from the point of view of the employees
it makes a ton of sense to have all of
that exhaling done outside the building
where it dissipates naturally rather
than accumulating there one sick person
could get every employee sick so
yeah okay next question
thank you for helping putting the thank
you for helping put the unity in
humanity that's
a stretch yeah spelling level but uh
you're welcome well
he found the letters in there they're
even in the right order that's cool yeah
given ali okay so this one um
we were told might have been asked a
little uh oddly just because there's
struggling with character limits let me
see if i can figure it out maybe you can
help me
um
[Music]
okay so it's basically this is a
question about negative assortative
mating so let me just
um give a little background first on um
in evolutionary biology we talk about
assortative mating
in which mate choice is based on
particular characteristics and positive
assertive mating
um is it's not a value judgment it
suggests that okay if i have blonde hair
which i don't
uh positive assertive mating for that
character would be me looking for a mate
with blonde hair
whereas negative assorted mating would
be me looking for a trait with the
with the opposite valence um so for you
know
dark hair uh so in with that framework
of positive
versus negative assertive mating this
person is basically
asked um
why women are often women in particular
more often than men are more likely to
engage in negative assorted mating
across
race and if that is the tr
if that is true so first we have this
observation that's a claim
if that observation is true given
um that alleles are are interested
uh in uh furthering themselves why
basically why would you ever have
negative assertive mating
well this is a great question yeah so
again i don't know if the pattern is
right
yeah but you have to factor in lots of
oh hold on just the final question here
was are they looking for immunological
enhancement for offspring that's a
that's a
possible explanation for why if the
observation is true it might be true
so um
possibly but not necessarily so i would
say look first of all there's a general
category of something called hybrid
vigor
right and i would say hybrid vigor you
know in the narrow
sense if you take two purebred dogs
they're liable to have
pathologies purebred dogs often do
if you breed them together
their offspring get the benefit
of uh genetic diversity and different
breeds
right right right that's what i mean
so i mean same thing same thing over
with cats
right you you know pure breeds often
have particular
problems that they reliably have whereas
you get um what you have dubbed
the epic tabby uh sub sub breed
yeah which you know tabi's are are mutts
at one level they're not exactly mutts
um although you know when they have the
white and the tabby with them
they're pretty muddy and uh
boy have we had a number of these epic
tabbies that are just you know
extraordinary in terms of their you know
it's going to sound like we're just
bragging about our cats but like a
couple of cats with this particular
phenotype that are extraordinary
cognitively yeah
they do seem to be a little too clever
for their own good sometimes
but in any case the hybrid vigor thing i
think
arises a lot because of the deficits of
purebreds
rather than because uh mixing is always
good in fact yes you know there's um
inbreeding depression there's deficits
from breeding too close to home
and there are costs from breeding too
far
and then you know purebreds uh have some
hybrid vigor when you mix them so the
distinction you're making is it might be
just avoidance of cost
not um adding unknown benefits well in
the case of humans
i'm going to make the argument that
probably this has very little to do with
genes
hybrid figure does right well a hybrid
vigor can work in terms of culture
also yes and i would say many of the
students
that we saw that showed the most extreme
potential
were actually hybrids right and my sense
is that this
cross-cultural so they had parents from
different places
from different places right and the
sense was actually you got some of the
wisdom from two different cultures
rather than getting two doses of wisdom
from one culture or something
yeah um but in this case you may even
have
an economic phenomenon right so the
question is
you're you know we are all in
competition with other
if assuming we are straight we are in
competition with other members of our
sex
for mates and people mate with the
highest quality person that they can
wrangle right superficially speaking
the quality of the person you can
wrangle may have a lot to do
with what the incentives are in the
population
from which you're wrangling and it may
be that women are
they get a better deal from males from a
different population
um so in other words it's like
i mean i hate to talk in these terms i
don't really hate to talk in these terms
i don't really think there's anything so
terrible about being
clear about this but i know that it will
freak people out but
the question is look you've got some
goods in which market are they worth the
most
and which market are they worth the most
in a currency that you value
right so it may be don't play around in
markets that you don't care about
right why do that but you know so the
question like put yourself in the
mindset of
uh you know like a woman i think i can
do that yeah it shouldn't be too too
much of a stretch for you
so put yourself in the mindset of a
woman maybe
the value is in having a really devoted
mate who's going to invest very heavily
rather than
a mate who's you know uh only kind of
paying attention and with which you
have a lot of freedom right those are
two different value sets and the point
is well
where would you find you know the
highest quality mate
with what you bring to the to the table
yeah uh
true it's a stretch to me to then jump
to you're more likely to find that
with via negative assorted mating for
phenotypic characters
um
unclear to me okay because the point is
you're
dealing with somebody on the other side
of that equation who has the same puzzle
as the inverse version right i just
don't see any reason to think it would
track
by things like ethnicity
um track it's not
necessarily the ethnicity it might be
the um let's say that you are
uh of the dominant population
it might be that you will find
a more devoted mate in a minority
population
because the deal is better from the
point of view of that individual of
their
offspring so if this is true the
prediction would be and i can get behind
this prediction i'm saying
i think it is somewhat more likely to be
true that
um this would be true only
for some groups and not for all
like that you would you would not expect
to find all groups negatively assertive
mating you know doing mate choice for
uh people who looked very much not like
them and therefore were probably from
somewhat different populations in recent
history i'm very skeptical that this is
a general pattern
but but might it be true for for some
groups especially if you add
you know it's going to sound post-modern
to some but like if you add the power
component if you
add the understanding of actually who is
wielding power and how is it that you
try to get the best deal for yourself in
an honorable way
yep humans have 23 chromosome pairs
all right this is true i believe the
militant moderate writes
that chromosome pair number two has been
found to be a combination of two ape
pairs since other great apes have 24
pairs
uh so i'm just going to keep on stepping
out to
add editorial comment it's true that uh
at least
chimps have 24 pairs i have never seen
an analysis of which we think
might have either been lost or fused in
humans um
so that is that is a claim that is being
made here but the part that we are 100
sure of is
humans of 23 at least chimps and i think
bonobos as well have 24 therefore
something happened there
do we know of other pairs of species and
which chromosomes have
fused
um i believe that that is not so
uncommon i think there's still a lot of
mystery about how uh chromosome number
changes yeah in animals and plants this
is relatively common
ploidy events well but so i was just
going to say you know ploidy events is
different from
a change in the haploid or the diploid
number right so ploidy
ploidy events to me tends to mean a
doubling tripling octupling whatever if
the entire genome so you know that's
that's what's going on so much with
frogs but they're crazy you know like
congeners can be you know tetraploid
versus
regular employed whatever that would be
um but
adding and dropping chromosomes i don't
even know exactly what we what we call
that i guess it's still a ploidy event
but it seems
it seems
you create a liberty to fuse something
so in other words initially what you
have is just a simple doubling
but downstream of that event descendants
that have inherited the doubled number
can alter something without interfering
with the original
genetic complement yeah but that so but
just like i'm saying
that's a very different set of
circumstances then for instance
great apes at least some great apes have
24 chromosomes we have 23.
there was presumably no doubling event
that then got us back to less than
in this case even if it was 24 to 26 i
think there's some great ape that has
maybe 26.
i was talking about so what i said was
that in animals there's still a great
deal of mystery about how these things
work i believe
yes in plants there's much less mystery
because these ploidy events happen
regularly okay and so um anyway there's
just a simple mechanism plants are also
less susceptible there's more room
to take um a structure
and radically alter it without
disrupting the fundamental nature of the
plant itself
their cells all of their cells tend to
remain pluripotent of not totipotent
they don't have segregated germ lines
they're just you know all
it's all different exactly it's all
different but it doesn't work that way
with elephants
not so much not so much yeah so um
i don't know a particular answer to this
and i think one of the things that you
can read from our answer is
uh neither of us is up on the most
recent thinking on this
but what we do believe is that there is
still a lot that is unknown and
therefore
probably some of what we think we
currently know won't turn out to be true
okay i'm gonna try to i'm gonna get
through a few more of these since we
just started
uh with this second one
is it possible that
is it i'm just going to read it exactly
as it's written
is possible that you have left yourself
vulnerable after today's podcast if in
the future you contract covid
what oh
that if we contract covid after talking
about how to avoid covid that we will be
mocked by our enemies or something oh
maybe maybe
maybe that's what it says i mean this
has been this has been the case
from the beginning because we've talked
about covet and our understanding of it
and
um the
yeah we're super careful but we might
get it i
worried that i had it at one point got
tested didn't have it um
clearly didn't have it based on uh what
unfolded so this is always a risk and
nobody you know as we if you go back to
the early live streams you will hear us
talking about the fact
that the only way is to be perfectly
safe
are unacceptable right right the level
of isolation is too high so you're
accepting some level of risk and
managing it is a
question that involves you having to set
a
you know a threshold but um yeah we
could get it and i really dread it
because
the uh even
low symptomatic cases seem to come with
a lot of damage
and there's a lot of uncertainty about
what it means going forward so
definitely to be avoided
oh boy next question during tuesday
night's debate trump issued a message to
the proud boys to stand down and stand
by
um was it stand down and stand by is
that what he said
something like that i think it's
important to get it right zach do you
remember what
he said exactly stand back and stand by
what did trump say stand
back and stand by to stand down is a
very different what i think would have
been
received i hope differently so i think
what he said was stand back and stand by
yeah what do you think are the
implications of this message
we are asked um you know
it was definitely dog whistly but i've
seen a lot of stuff
because the nature of the question
involved
fusing the proud boys to
white supremacists who were undefined
there's an awful lot of shell game going
along going
in tandem with this so stand back and
stand by
could mean a lot of things the proud
boys are troubling
it's a frightening organization and
what they stand for um isn't entirely
clear but what what i've seen people do
is because he issued that in response to
a question in which white supremacists
were called out but not
named yeah it is unclear
people have used that to portray him as
telling white supremacists to stand
back and stand by no but he seems to
have been specifically responding
to with regard to proud boys right so
you know we really
it has to be separated like white
supremacists like are there white
supremacist organizations yes
for sure can we go to the uh southern
poverty law center to decide who they
are
no not anymore they've been captured
unfortunately like they were useful and
they're dead now like we just can't use
them on their list is proud boys a white
supremacist
organization well it's certainly on some
people's lists
i don't i i'm still on the fence
but i don't think so if i mean if i had
to decide if i had to declare right now
is proud boys a white supremacist
organization i would say i don't know i
don't think so yeah from what i've seen
i don't know right so but if you had if
you're like okay but you you
tell us right now like if you have to
you have to decide yes yeah
i would say undoubtedly or almost
undoubtedly there are white supremacists
in the proud boys what that has to do
with what the proud boys are about
i don't know and i also don't want
responsibility for figuring it out right
the point is
the hubbub around this answer has to do
with you know even having asked ask the
question
in this form makes it difficult to know
what the answer would mean
i think it was an irresponsible question
if you want to ask about white
supremacists
fine if you want to ask about proud boys
fine but well i think if if memory
serves i think he
i think chris wallace did ask about
white supremacists and
gosh i hope i'm not getting this wrong
but i think trump said but who like who
are we talking about or
some something to that effect and or he
said well of course i denounce
but like which one's white supremacist
but like who specifically
are we talking about and it's that where
he's
he's easily described he's reliably
described by everyone
on the left who wants to see it as he is
himself
advocating for white supremacism and
racism
but we also see exactly those same
people those exact same institutions
saying that his official memorandum on
not using critical race theory in
federal um
agencies as evidence of his white
supremacy and racism and that is not
like that we can be 100 clear about so
you know does he does he play footsie
with uh some
unsavory and worse groups yeah yeah he
does and i
really really wish he wouldn't yeah
right yeah not because i voted for the
guy or i'm going to vote for the guy
or i like him but just like we deserve
better as americans
to not have a president who's willing to
do that but
is he um potentially
trying to do right by organizations that
are you know questionable in their
methods
and ethos but actually not the thing
that they are slandered with
if it is from pax lander maybe he's just
trying to be careful like
that doesn't seem like the guy that
we've seen but um
wouldn't it be great if he was just
trying not
to sign on with a sort of
across-the-board claim that anyone who
disagrees with woke culture for instance
is interested in white supremacy because
that certainly isn't true yeah that
isn't true but
at some level i i just don't like this
landscape at all
right yeah we are somehow getting
involved in
you know us having to figure out what
the proud boys are i didn't sign up
and what trump was thinking what trump
was thinking and all that so
at some level i would say look what i
want is for the president to say
um you know we all need to rise above
this that
our interest as americans involves
regarding each other
uh as you know important
and yeah that any organization that
wants to divide us is a problem
yeah and you know we didn't get that out
of him
um yep so yeah
it is what it is i suppose
timeline integrated sensory experience
oral language pictographics phonics
printing press which comes with
gatekeepers social media
everyone can publish smartphones
everyone can publish video
i think there's a lot in that and um
there's no question
but it's a it's a worthy timeline to
have described
i'm wondering why integrated sensory
experiences before oral language i
wonder if i'd maybe a misunderstanding
what that means
yeah i integrated sensory experience
might
to me looks like what all social
organisms
have um i don't i mean maybe it can mean
a lot of different things and
oh it's integrated within an individual
well no social organisms are integrating
their sensory experience with other
individuals you know
in order to have something like theory
of mind and
um just being social is you are you are
sharing sensory experience
um i'm just not not buying that we know
that
don't be we know what that the fact that
an animal is social
means that it is sharing sensory
experience
so because social doesn't social doesn't
inherently mean
that you have theory of mind it just
means that you're interacting with other
members of your species
yeah so if you're interacting with other
members of your species how are you
doing except with your senses
well okay but um
integrated sensory experience i mean
it's it's not a ter i think it needs
more
we either need to define it and it's not
a term that we've ever
seen before integrating sensory
experience
we need to define it first i don't think
this is an interesting game to play
without defining the term
and it's not a term that exists in our
landscape
so i'm sure there's something real there
so i took it as one thing you took it to
something else
could be the person writing the question
took it as something else entirely
but regardless you have some kind of
shared sensory experience and then oral
language than pictographics
meaning like cave drawings right um
phonics what is what is what is i'm not
sure what phonics is then
printing press which has gatekeepers
social media in which everyone can
publish and then smartphones when
everyone can publish videos so at one
level
this strikes me as alluding to um
this analysis by walter ong in a book um
boy 50s 60s 70s i can't remember which
called orality and literacy
in which he is um arguing
that um oral cultures cultures without a
written language
and you know he at that point called
them pre-literate and increasingly
anthropologists would like us to call
them
non-literate because they aren't
inherently going to literacy nor
aspiring to literacy
um but sort of you know oral oral
exclusive cultures have very different
ways of being and understanding the
world
than literary cultures do and walter ong
began to ask whether or not we might
have a returned oral ways of thinking
even back in the gosh i don't remember
if it was 50 60 70s
but specifically with the advent of
social media
people began saying okay actually this
begins to look like even though it's in
text that the ways that we are
communicating now are much more like
oral societies did
and it's confusing to us because we have
an entire societal framework based on
a literate understanding of you know a
literate society understanding
uh and i i won't say much more than that
right now but we might come back to it
because it's
actually pretty fascinating
done yep okay a company called elysium
created by biophds sells nad plus
supplements that promote a healthy aging
process
and activates for two ones on health
truth or bs i feel like we got this
exact this question before yeah
um you know look if you have a
deficiency
there's a lot to be said for a
supplement if you don't have a
deficiency it's very hard to enhance the
functioning
of the organism beyond what
selection does there are places this
might not be
right but they're going to be the
exception i can't speak to it directly
but
i'm skeptical yeah and the idea that
every human
that every human has a deficiency that
could be fixed by a supplement
is suggests a pretty radical
misunderstanding of evolution because if
it could be fixed that way why didn't
selection fix it
yeah i mean so unless it's a novelty
issue like vitamin d
either a novelty issue or a pathology
of some sort largely you know broadly
speaking that affects some
some number of people but not but not
all people
okay let's do um two
more um
what do you believe evolution is is it a
force of nature a simple algorithm
encoded in the data of life or perhaps a
mathematical function like a chaotic
attractor or other emergent phenomenon
keep up the good work
and this is from chop resident
chop resident the chop house
the answer to that is that we've talked
about this a little bit before
there are four parameters that cause a
pattern to become
common in the universe they have to do
with either
reproduction or the tendency to come
into being the
tendency to uh
be self-similar the tendency
to um stick around once created and the
tendency to accumulate
limited materials that's
selection and it creates every pattern
that is non-biotic
you get into a biotic milieu you add one
thing to it which is heredity
then you get adaptation and when you we
say evolution typically we mean
adaptation and the
answer is this is an automatic
uh it is in some sense
a nearly tautological consequence
of preconditions that will result in
patterns becoming more common and then
those
features that cause increases in
commonality accumulating through
adaptation
excellent um would you accept the three
word definition
descent with modification well if we
you know if we're being literal about
what we think the question asker
means what do you believe evolution is
right i understand what they've asked
but the problem is
evolution which uh does not
involve anything interesting as its
product
is simply uh genetic change within a
population
over time but can't that be
crunched down to descent with
modification that can
but if you think that um that is
tantamount to
adaptation which is what people
typically mean when they say evolution
right
then it's insufficient right it's it's
insufficient
um but evolution to something
modification change over time never good
enough
and that's that's the thing that people
think they think and in fact i was
listening to an otherwise really good
podcast this morning in which the
author of this book who knew a lot about
what he was talking about but as usual
didn't really know anything about
evolution said you know that evolution
you know change that's what evolution is
like
no rocks change over time and they don't
evolve descent with modification
is the shortest
definition that actually seems inclusive
we have an insect that has invaded the
house and our epic tabby is
interested in eating it
okay one more question is unity 2020
finished
going forward how about american unity
name change do either of you know where
your vote will go at this point
that was three questions yeah i'll fight
you naked
there's three questions
it says that okay no that's that's
that's
oh that's i thought that threw me all
right
so uh is unity 2020. exactly what this
person has been hoping for
unity 2020 is um
suspended it could be unsuspended
if crazy events caused it to be viable
again and we have gotten
a crazy event that has not yet created
the opportunity for unity 2020 but
depending upon how things unfold it
could
so um no it's not finished unity itself
the unity movement is certainly not
finished
and uh
you know there is a question i want to
say anything about that about unity
unity not unity 2020 going forward
um yes well i can say that we are taking
steps to build an organization um we
have so far done everything
without money and that has been
good in one way but it's obviously
limiting in another way so we are
realizing that with more time we will
need to build an entity
that is capable of taking donations and
using them
well so anyway we're in the process of
building that
and you know there's no question that
there needs to be a unity movement and
it needs to
bring to an end this cycle of
polarization that's putting the republic
in so much jeopardy so
whether there's an opportunity in 2020
we don't know but going forward
there better be because we need it
that's right all right well i think
we've reached the end
of episode 48 q a we encourage you to
like this video subscribe to the channel
join us at one or both of our patreons
for access to private q a
discord uh long-form conversations
with brett and some other goodies there
we will be back probably next saturday
for the time being we're going to be
doing this once a week
hopefully with brett adding a non-live
uh dark horse podcast on the regular
um we might move the once a week to a
weekday so that we can
free our weekends to be with our
children and not just our animals
and uh anything else no i think that
about does it
uh it's been fun we will see you next
saturday
all right be well
[Music]
you